Peter how are you holding up man I'm
good good good tough tough tough
decision huh yeah well is it for the
best and uh you know all love in the
world to not eat an ant so did your
mother did she play an influence in this
a lot of people are given her backlash
various no she didn't this is stuff
between Matt and I solely for one in
seven people have their opinions but
this is just between the two of us and
it's just a mutual respect and love and
that's all some people think your mother
should have her own reality show what do
you think about that I love it you love
it would you do what you do it with her
all right buddy thanks maddie is hanging
out with Selena Selena Gomez what do you
think of that uh I don't know that do
you know that yeah I got asked about
Julie la placa rumors what's that Julie
la placa the producer Yeah right you
guys possible are you open - she's my
producer man she's a good friend so
you're not gonna touch that it's bad way
to put it but you're not going anywhere
near that okay all right last question
coronavirus you're a pilot
Yeah right any precautions are you
worried concerned just washing my hands
man honest I think it's a little bit
more fear-based right now unwarranted
fear but I understand the panic and
hopefully it clears up soon so all right
it backed back to your mom reality show
yeah maybe she'd kill it she's like the
most entertaining lady I love my mom so
yeah that via I definitely want to have
they reached out because there's a lot
of people saying right how am i I'm not
sure man but yeah well see are you a you
and your mom right I mean the way that
she handled herself on the show right
has that caused any tension between you
and your family at all no we're good
that's we're just plus there's a Cuban
family dynamic - it's a lot of passion
and my mom of the delivery been a little
different sure but her her message was
OnPoint she wants the best for me and
just loves me and very grateful to have
a mom like that well very cool does she
have any regrets though no some people
think that maybe she owes Maddie an
apology for the way that the way that
she kind of approached I think both of
them you know could have handled
situations a little bit differently yeah
and I listen no one's perfect but you
know all the respect and love for Maddie
and I love my mom's last question what's
next for you I got a trip on Sunday so
back to this guy all right buddy thank
you thanks good luck
[Music]